[موسيقى]
حصاد هذه الليله معي انا يا ابي عاصي
مرحبا بكم في الوقت الذي احدثكم فيه تقع
احداث وتتفاعل اخرى هذه اللقطات من
نيويورك والحدث المتصدر امريكيا الرئيس
السابق دونالد ترامب يصل للوصول امام
المحكمه غدا وهذه الصور لتاور مقر اقامه
حيث من المفترض ان يصل بعد قليل
هذه اللقطات من مينيسوتا للرئيس الامريكي
جو بايدن الذي يقدم ايجازا بشان خطته
الاقتصاديه
وهذه الصور تريدنا مباشره من مكه المكرمه
وتعكس اجواء الحرم في شهر رمضان بعيدا
انتهاء صلاه التراويح
وفي مواضيع الحصاد لهذه الليله
بعد اقتحام قوات الاحتلال نابلس وقتلها
شابين فلسطينيين اطلاق نار يستهدف قوه
اسرائيليه ومستوطنه في شمال الضفه وعلى
وقع التصعيد الميداني نتنياهو يؤجل اقاله
وزير دفاعه وتهم جنائيه سابقه تطارد وتهدد
بقائه في وزاره الامن القومي
في اكبر اتساع لحدود النيتو المباشره مع
روسيا فنلندا تنضم بشكل رسمي الى الحلف
يقول انضمامها سيجعل الحلف اقوى روسيا
تعلن تعزيز قوتها ردا على الانضمام وتقول
ان الاسلحه النوويه التكتيكيه المزمع
نقلها الى بيلاروسيا ستتمركز غربا
باخمت وجدل السيطره بعد اعلان ميليشيا
فارغنر التحكم في مركز المدينه كياف تقول
انها افشلت هجوما جديدا
وتتهم القوات الروسيه بتزييف الحقائق
لاخفاء اخفاقاتها والبيت الابيض يؤكد
استمرار المعارك في باخمت
عشيه مثوله امام المحكمه في نيويورك بموجب
تهم جنائيه فريق الدفاع يؤكد ان ترامب
سيدفع ببراءته وسلطات المدينه تنفي وجود
تهديدات حقيقيه وتؤكد ضمان حق التعبير
بطرق سلميه بالتزامن مع محاكمه ترامب
في لقائنا اليومي قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه ناقشنا خبر مثول الرئيس الامريكي
السابق غدا امام المحكمه في نيويورك بعد
ان غادر اليوم ولايه فلوريدا وصرح عمده
نيويورك بتشديد الاجراءات الامنيه تحسبا
لاحتجاجات متوقعه لاستطلاع ارائكم بشان
هذا الموضوع كنا قد طرحنا عليكم السؤال
التالي كيف سيمر مثول ترامب امام المحكمه
غدا
36% قالوا ان الوضع سيمر بشكل طبيعي دون
تداعيات فيما راى 35% انه سيكون هناك
احتجاجات محدوده بينما صوت 29% لامكانيه
حدوث احتجاجات كبيره وصدامات
هذا سؤال سيبقى مطروحا على منصاتنا
الرقميه ويمكنكم دخول صفحه التصويت عبر
مسح رمز كيو ار الظاهري على الشاشه
لقائنا على المنصات الرقميه يتجدد يوميا
وتتطرق خلاله لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعله
عربيا ودوليا
[موسيقى]
نبدا اذا من الاراضي الفلسطينيه حيث شهدت
الضفه الغربيه قبل قليل تطورات امنيه اذ
اعلن الجيش الاسرائيلي تعرض مستوطنه شرق
جنين لاطلاق نار في مقاله وسائل اسراء
وسائل اعلام اسرائيليه ان قوه عسكريه
اسرائيليه قرب حواره تعرضت ايضا لاطلاق
نار هذا وكان القوات الاحتلال اقتحمت
اليوم مدينه نابلس وقتلت شابين فلسطينيين
وقالت انها نفذت العمليه لاعتقال مطلوبين
على صله بهجوم حواره الذي وقع قبل اسبوع
وادى الى اصابه ثلاثه جنود اسرائيليين
وقال شهود عيان فلسطينيون ان اشتباكات
مسلحا دلعت خلال الاقتحام
بينما كان اهالي نابلس يستعدون لصوم اليوم
الثاني عشر من الشهر الفضيل كانت قوات من
وحدات النخبه واليات عسكريه اسرائيليه
تقتحم المدينه من ثلاثه محاور الهدف وفق
الاحتلال اعتقال فلسطينيين بشبهه مساعده
منفذي عمليه حوار الاخيره والتي ادت الى
اصابه جنديين
لم يمهل الجنود العائلات التي تحتمي
بمنازلها ففجروا ابواب عدد من المنازل
وعاثوا فيها خرابا وحاصروا العائلات
مستخدمين الاسلحه والكلاب اصوبوا علينا
تحت التهديد طب قلنا له احنا هون بيت عيله
ما عنا انه شباب فش شوي لما
الباب طار العافيه كله راح بطلع شو في ضرب
علينا وسيل وسط هذا الخوف تصدت عناصر
المقاومه لقوات الاحتلال رد الجنود باطلاق
الرصاص الحي فاستشهد مقاومان محمد ابو بكر
من كتائب شهداء الاقصى الذراع المسلحه
لحركه فتح من بلده جنيد ومحمد الحلاق من
مجموعه عرين الاسود من مخيم العين
شيع الشهيدين الاف الفلسطينيين يتقدمهم
مقاومون مسلحون ولكن نقول هذا الاحتلال
مارس ارهابكم مارسوا قتلكم مارس تدميركم
فان سنبقى هنا لكم في مدينه نابلس وفي
مدينه جنين وفي مدينه اريحا وفي جميع
مواقع التكتلات العسكريه وفي مدينه طولكرم
الرد السريع باننا سنبقى لكم مقارعين
مقاتلين مقاومين فلن يرهبنا ولن يستثني
عزيمتنا وفي بلده الظاهريه قضاء الخليل
شيع الاهالي جثمان الشهيد سنه سمامره الذي
كانت قوات الاحتلال تحت جيز جثمانه منذ
ثلاثه اشهر
قائل الفلسطينيه كافه اجمعت على ضروره
مواصله المقاومه اما الحكومه الفلسطينيه
فطالبت المجتمع الدولي خصوصا الولايات
المتحده بالزام الاحتلال باحترام
الاتفاقيات السياسيه
في الاراضي الفلسطينيه المحتله غضب عارف
قياس او تفاهمات ولا يقيم وزنا لحرمه
الشهر الفضيل بل ويواصل القتل والاعتقال
والتدمير لتبقى القشه من انفجار ميداني
اكبر الايام المقبله الجزيره نابلس
قالت هيئه البث الاسرائيليه نقلا عن مصدر
سياسي ان نتنياهو ارجا قراره باقاله وزير
الدفاع
نظرا لتطورات الوضع الامني المعقد وان
نتنياهو سينظر في امر وزير الدفاع في وقت
لاحق وقال نتنياهو امام تجمع للجنود
الاسرائيليين بحضور انه يجب ابقاء سياسه
خارج بوابات المعسكرات من جهته قال جالنت
انه يجب التخلي او التحلي بالوحده في
مواجهه من وصفهم باعداء اسرائيل
انهت المحكمه العليا الاسرائيليه جلسه
للنظر في التماس ضد تعيين ايتامار بن جفير
وزيرا في الحكومه حيث ستعلن قرارها في وقت
لاحق وكان بنجفير قد مثل نفسه امام
المحكمه بعد ان رفض ان تقوم المستشاره
القضائيه للحكومه بالدفاع عنه ويحتج
مقدموه الالتماس على تعيين في هذا المنصب
الحساس بسبب ماضيه الجنائي وتاييده لباروخ
جولد منفذ مجزره المسجد الابراهيمي في
الخليل عام 1994 كما جرت الاشاره في
الالتباس الى تصريحات سابقه لرئيس الوزراء
بنيامين نتانياهو قال فيها ان ابن جبير لن
يشغل منصب وزير في حكومته وقد وصف بن جفير
المحكمه بانها اشبه بالسرك بعد ان انتفض
خلال النقاش وهجم كلاميا المدعين عليه
وقال في معرض الدفاع عن نفسه انه ارتكب
اخطاء في الماضي لكنه اليوم شخص مختلف
من الناصره ينضم الينا الدكتور سليم بريك
المحاضر في العلوم السياسيه بالجامعه
المفتوحه في حيفا والخبير في الشؤون
الاسرائيليه مرحبا بك دكتور سليم بريك لو
بدانا من هذا الالتماس المقدم الى المحكمه
العليا الاسرائيليه بشان
ماديه هذه المحاكمه وكيف يمكن ان تنعكس
على توليه منصبا في الحكومه
مساء الخير الالتماس مهم جدا ويدل على
اهتمام
بتركيبه الحكومه ولكن عمليه كل ما حدث في
المحكمه هو متوقع باعتقادي انه هذه
المحاكمه ليست
وتعيين بين وزيره للامن القومي هذه
المحاكمه عمليا هي للمجتمع الاسرائيلي
الذي تدهور من وضع فيه كان بينفير ملاحق
من قبل سلطات القضاء في اسرائيل
ويتحول لوزير مسؤول عن شرطه اسرائيل
ومسؤول بشكل او باخر ايضا حتى عن اجهزه
القضاء باعتباره له تمثيل في لجنه تعيين
القضاه هذا يدل على الى اين يتدهور
المجتمع الاسرائيلي اخلاقيا حتى وجود
حزبين ينتميين لافكار فاشيه وافكار عنصريه
يهوديه ضد كل من هو ليس يهودي هذا شيء
مهين لكل المجتمع الاسرائيلي وهذا يدل
ايضا الى
اين يمكن ان تصبح هذه المحاكمه
انا باعتقادي هذا المحاكمه لن تاتي باي
نتائج حقيقيه في نهايه المطاف المحكمه
العليا ايضا تخشى الحكومه نحن نرى الان
ملاحقه للمحكمه العليا في
في الحكومه الاسرائيليه
القضاه يدركون بانهم تحت تهديد من هذه
الحكومه الان هناك مفاوضات حول الانقلاب
على نظام الحكم فاعتقادي في نهايه المطاف
لن تتدخل المحكمه في تعيين وزير خصوصا
بانه لا توجد اسباب مباشره لالغاء هذا
التعيين ولكن في نهايه المطاف كما اسلفت
هذا يدل على الوضع الموجود فيه المجتمع
الاسرائيلي اليوم طيب ازمه اخرى يحاول
نتنياهو تطويقها في هذه الحكومه فيما
يتعلق بوضع يوئاف جالنت يقول انه جرى
تاجيل اقاله وزير الدفاع ما دلالات ذلك
وفعلا يتصرف كانه ملك او حاكم وحيد في
دوله اسرائيل هو عمليا يسير وراء اهواء
ابنه
على هذا الاساس وقام بقاله جلند باعتقاد
هذا كان خطا من ناحيه نتنياهو وهذا اثار
غضب الشارع الان نتنياهو من ناحيه لا
يستطيع ان يتنازل عن هذا الالغاء ومن
الناحيه الثانيه هو لا يستطيع اقاله جالنت
لانه يدرك بان لاسباب امنيه وايضا لاسباب
اجتماعيه سياسيه هو لا يستطيع القيام بذلك
ولذلك ويفتش عن حل وسط بعمليه تذويب هذا
الموضوع بشكل او باخر
ويبقى غالنت مستضعف في الحكومه يعني في
هنا وضع غير طبيعي ان العلاقات غير جيده
بين وزير الدفاع ورئيس الحكومه من ناحيه
وزير الدفاع لا يعرف اذا كان سيستمر في
منصبه ام لا هذا
يضعه في وضع ضعيف امام رئيس الحكومه وبهذه
الطريقه يسيطر رئيس الحكومه على كل مركبات
حزب الليكود طيب هذه الازمات في داخل
الحكومه
يوازيها تصعيد ضد الفلسطينيين في الضفه
تصعيد في غزه تصعيد في الساحه السوريه
لماذا ماذا يفهم من وراء كل ذلك
اولا نفهم نراك كل ذلك بان حكومه اسرائيل
تستطيع ان تفعل ما تشاء ولا احد يسالها
يعني الولايات المتحده لا ترد على تصرفات
اسرائيل
ربما لا ترد على الصرافات السريه حتى
الدول العربيه لا ترد على اسرائيل يعني ما
بقي السلطه الفلسطينيه عمليا تقريبا
موجوده لوحدها امام اسرائيل الان ربما بعد
الدعم من الاردن
وحكومه اسرائيل تش
عر بان كل شيء الان نسال نفسنا ماذا حدث
في العقبه وماذا حدث في شرم الشيخ يعني
اذا كان هناك اتفاق بخفض التصعيد فلماذا
اسرائيل لا تحترم هذا الاتفاق وان كانت
اسرائيل لا تحترم هذا الاتفاق فاين الدول
الراعيه لهذا اللقاء اين الولايات المتحده
واين مصر واين الاردن يعني لا يمكن ابقاء
الفلسطينيين لوحدهم الفلسطينيين وخصوصا
السلطه الفلسطينيه هي ضعيفه من ناحيه
الدبلوماسيه هي ايضا ضعيفه اخرى مثل
الاقتصاديه والاخره تتعلق بشكل مطلق
باسرائيل واسرائيل تفعل ما تشاء لانها لا
ترى اي رد فعل الدول العربيه لا تقوم
بواجبها اتجاه الشعب الفلسطيني وهذه حقيقه
يجب ان نضعها على الطاوله شكرا لك من
الناصره الدكتور سليم بريك المحاضر في
العلوم السياسيه بالجامعه المفتوحه في
حيفا والخبير في الشؤون الاسرائيليه شكرا
[موسيقى]
اعلنت فنلندا انها ستنضم غدا الى النيتو
وقال الامين العام للحلف
ان هذه الخطوه ستجعل حلف الناتو اقوى ويعد
تسريع انضمام فنلندا والسويد للحلف من
ابرز نتائج حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا ويتوقع
ان يؤدي الانضمام الى رسم خريطه جيو
استراتيجيه جديده في شمال اوروبا كما انه
يفرض على روسيا تحديات جديده لم تكن
موجوده قبل اندلاع الحرب في اوكرانيا
من اهم المبررات التي ساقتها موسكو لشن
حربها على اوكرانيا زحف الناتو شرقا في
اتجاه الحدود الروسيه لكن هذه الحرب دفعت
فنلندا والسويد لطلب عضويه الحلف فماذا
تعني هذه العضويه تعني اقتراب الحلف اكثر
فعمليا سيضيف الناتو300 كيلومتر من الحدود
مع روسيا وستمكنه الحدود الفنلنديه من
اطول حدود بريه معها وهذا ما سيعزز وجود
الناتو في منطقه بالغه الحساسيه وهي بحر
البلقي في عام 2004 انضمت دول البلطيقه
الثلاث ليتوانيا
للحلف لكن صغر حجمها والبعد عن مركز الثقل
في الحلف جعلت تلك الدول تعيش خوفا دائما
من جارها الروسي الان بانضمام فنلندا وفي
انتظار انضمام السويد سيتعزز امن هذه
الدول الصغيره منطقه اخرى لا تخفى اهميه
الاستراتيجيه هي القطب الشمالي الوضع
الجغرافي لفندا والسويد سيمنح الحلف نفودا
اوسع في المنطقه الشاسعه بعد اكمال انض ما
يشكل تهديدا للمصالح الاستراتيجيه لروسيا
التي استثمرت كثيرا هناك بعد ان اظهرت
الدراسات غنى المنطقه بالثروات الطبيعيه
تعد مملكه السويد من الدول القليله في
شمال اوروبا التي تعاملت بالنديه مع روسيا
القيصريه طوال قرون وخادت معها حروبا لبسط
النفود هناك ولذلك فعندما يكتمل انضمامها
الى الحلف ستجد روسيا نفسها امام تحدي لا
يستهان به وما يزيد من حجم هذا التحدي ان
السويد تعد قوه عسكريه كبيره وتملك صناعه
حربيه من بين الافضل في العالم فهي تصنع
غواصات وصواريخ وطائرات متطوره وتملك
سلاحا جويا يعد من الافضل في اوروبا
والعالم كما تملك قوه بحريه لا يستهان بها
اما الجيش السويدي فهو جيش محترف يعتمد
على التقنيات الحديثه ويملك عتادا متطورا
وانضمامه الى الحرب سيقويه ويزيده فعاليه
في الشمال الاوروبي ورغم ان قوه فنلندا
العسكريه اقل من السويد فان وضعها
الجغرافي ربما يجعل انضمامها اكثر ازعاجا
لروسيا فرسيا التي ساعدت لابعاد النيتو
تجده الان يجاورها على امتداد مئات
الكيلومترات وقبل الانضمام بسنوات قامت
فنلندا بعمليه تحديث لجيشها وخاصه ميزانيه
كبيره للدفاع
المدير العام لسياسات الدفاعيه في وزاره
الدفاع الفنلنديه مرحبا بك سيد يانكوسيلا
هل كانت فنلندا بالفعل بحاجه للانضمام الى
الناتو وهي التي تتمتع بعلاقات ممتازه مع
روسيا
لاوكرانيا
وطبعا تغيرت بيئه الامن اوروبيه بشكل كامل
واستنادا الى هذا التغيير وصلنا الى
استنتاج في فنلندا مفرده ان من الافضل لنا
ان ننضم الى حلف النيتو ولكن ما النتيجه
الان بالاعلان عن انضمامكم الى حلف الناتو
تعلن روسيا انها ستعسكر الحدود مع فنلندا
وهو ما لم يكن حاصل سابقا
الاثر الرئيسي اللي فنلندا اننا الان ضدنا
جزءا من تحالف يضم واحدا وثلاثين دوله
وهذا يشكل دعما كبيرا للدفاع فنلندا وترى
فنلندا ان هذا الامر سيلعب دورا كبيرا
ويضيف الكثيره لامننا القومي لكن
المسؤولين روسيا يقولون ان هذا التهديد
الذي تخشاه فنلندا لم يكن موجودا اصلا وان
انضمامها الى الناتو الان
يوجد هذا التهديد الروسي يعني ياتي بنتيجه
عكسيه على فنلندا كيف تردون على ذلك
تاويلنا وتفسيرنا للامور مختلف تماما
الانضمام الى النيتو ليس موجها بشكل مباشر
ضد اي ترفع
هو تحالف او حلف
ركز على الدفاع عن اعضائه وهو لم يكن
موجها ضد اي بلد اخر ولكن ربما ليس هذا ما
تفهمه روسيا لان المسؤولين الروس لن
يتحدثون عن نشر الاسلحه النوويه التكتيكيه
على الحدود مع فنلندا على الحدود الغربيه
لروسيا
انا اترك هذا الامر للسلطات الروسيه انا
لست في موقع يتيح للتعليق على مثل هذه
الامور لكن كيف تعتقد يمكن للسلطات
الفنلنديه ان تتعامل مع هكذا معطى
سنتعامل مع الامر كما فعلنا دائما
فنلندا دائما احتفظت لنفسها بقدرات دفاعيه
كبيره الان نحن معنا حلف باسره وكما قلت
انضمامنا لهذا الحلف ليس موجها ضد اي دوله
نحن بلد صغير وسكان لا يتجاوزون خمسه ونصف
مليون نسمه ونحن دائما بحاجه الى تعزيز
امننا شكرا لك ينكوسيلا المدير العام
لسياسات الدفاعيه في وزاره الدفاع
الفنلنديه ضيفنا من هيلسنكي
في ردي موسكو اعلن الكسندر جروشكو نائب
ووزير الخارجيه الروسي ان بلادها ستعزز
امنها العسكري على المحورين الغربي
والشمالي الغربي ردا على انضمام فنلندا
الى النيتو وكان السفير الروسي لدى
بيلاروسيا قال ان الاسلحه التكتيكيه
النوويه ستنقل الى الحدود الغربيه لدوله
الاتحاد اي بيلاروسيا بهدف تعزيز امن
البلدين اضاف جريز لوف في مقابله
تلفزيونيه انا نقل هذه الاسلحه الى الحدود
الغربيه سيتم رغم احتجاج اوروبا والولايات
المتحده واشار الى انه بحلول الاول من
يوليو تموز المقبل وفقا للرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين ستجهز منشاه تخزين لنشر
اسلحه نوويه تكتيكيه في بيلاروسيا
من موسكو معنا
محرر شؤون الدوليه بصحيفه
يقول بوتين ذهب الى الحرب ضد اوكرانيا
ليبعد الناتو وهو العكس يحصل في اشاره الى
انضمام فنلندا ما رايك
في البدايه
نقول ان تدخل روسيا في المواجهه في
اوكرانيا لا علاقه له ابدا بفنلندا بالطبع
هناك تفسير بان الامر كله جزء من قصه
كبيره لكن القضيه هي ان روسيا لم تكن تهدد
فنلندا وكما قال ضيفكم الفنلندي قال ان
فنلندا تخافوا روسيا لكن امل ان تتفقوا
معي في القول بان هذا ليس عقلانيا لان
التعزيز امن اي بلد يتم وفقا لحسابات وليس
بالاستناد الى مخاوف لان هذا الاستناد لا
مخاوف سياتي بنتائج سيئه نحن ناسف ذلك بغض
النظر كل ذلك هذه تبريرات ولكن الحقيقه
الان الحقيقه الان هو ان الناتو اصبح
يتشارك مع روسيا بحدود طولها تقريبا 1300
كم
هذا صحيح انتم تضحكون تماما الان نتقاسم
حدودا اكثر من الف كيلو متر وهذه حدود
طويله لكن طبعا هذه الحدود تم ترسيمها بعد
حروب داميه ايام الاتحاد
السوفيتي كنا في نزاعا مع فنلندا في
الماضي لكن الان وبعد هدوء طويل ولكن بعد
انضمام فنلندا على روسيا ان تقتم على
خطوات من جانبها ايضا روسيا بالطبع سترى
كيف تعزز انها رايتم اخبارا عن نشر
قنابل نوويه تكتيكيه في بيلاروسيا هذا يجب
ان يكون مثل الماء البارد الذي يصب على
فنلندا لتستيقظ من سباتها ربما الفنلندا
ستصبح اكثر ضعفا
عندما تقول ان على فنلندا ان تستيقظ من
سباتها
سباتها ماذا تعني بهذا الامر هل هناك توقع
في موسكو ربما ان تعود فنلندا عن هذه
الخطوه بالانضمام الى الناتو
كلا لا اقول هذا لا ليس ممكنا العوده الى
الوراء وعكس هذا القرار الشيطان يكمن في
التفاصيل كما يقولون وما هي التداعيات
العمليه لانضمام فنلندا الى حلف النيت على
سبيل المثال هل ستكون هناك قوات نوويه
تكتيكيه سيتم نشرها في فنلندا او لا كيف
سيكون تعزيز القوات داخل فنلندا فنلندا
تقول سنقلل من نش القوى نحن لا نصدق ذلك
ونحن نقول ان
سيفعلون ما تمليه عليهم بروكسل لكنهم
اورطوا انفسهم
وسيتورطون اكثر في نزاعا عسكري اذا ما
تخلوا عن حياديتهم وستكون القرفه باهظه
شكرا لك محرر شؤون الدوليه بصحيفه
كوميرسنت ضيفنا من موسكو
كيف تطورت خريطه حلف الناتو وكيف تطورت
مهامه وخططه موضوع ناقشه بشكل اوسع ضمن
فقره في المتابعه
[موسيقى]
الى اوكرانيا حيث لا يزال القتال محتدما
في مدينه بخموت ونقلت وكاله نيفوستي ان
القوات الروسيه اقتربت من خط السكه
الحديديه الرئيسى وقد احدث وفي احدث
التطورات بث رئيس شركه فاجنر صورا ليليه
له قال فيها انه يرفع العلم الروسي على
المركز الاداري في المدينه
من جانبها قالت الرئاسه الاوكرانيه ان
باخموت لا تزال تحت سيطره قواتها ولفت
اخبار سيطره القوات الروسيه عليها وقال
متحدث باسم قياده القوات الاوكرانيه في
الشرق ان الجيش الروسي
بعيد عن الاستيلاء على بخمه مضيفا ان
القتال يدور بالقرب من مبنى اداره باخمه
ان الجيش يواصل دفاعه عن المدينه وقالت
القوات الاوكرانيه انها افشلت هجوما روسيا
شمال غرب اخ القوات الروسيه تحاول اخفاء
فشلها ببث اخبار مزيفه بشان السيطره على
المدينه
في واشنطن قال منسق والاتصالات
الاستراتيجيه في مجلس الامن القومي
الامريكي جون كيربي ان القوات الاوكرانيه
لا تزال تقاتل بضراوه في ضخمه وان المعركه
هناك لم تنتهي بعد اضاف كيربي ان
الاوكرانيين لا يزالون في بخموت ولم
يطردوا منها وليس بامكانه تاكيد ما اذا
كان الجنود الروس قد سيطروا على المبنى
الحكومي فيها
المعركه على بخمو تكاد تكون من اكثر
المعارك ضراوطا منذ بدايه الحرب الروسيه
على اوكرانيا لا يمكن معرفه الخسائر لدى
الجانبين على نحو دقيق فروسيا واوكرانيا
لا تتحدثان سوى عن السيطره على بخموت او
الاحتفاظ بها
اوكرانيا دفعت الى المعركه بنخبه من
قواتها المقاتله يتمركز فيها مقاتلون
اللواء الثالث والتسعين ومقاتلون من كتيبه
ازوف بينما يقاتل جنود اللواء الثاني
والتسعين في مناطق محاذيه لابقاء القوات
الروسيه منشغله اما من الجانب الروسي
فتقود ميليشيا فاجنر الهجوم على المدينه
بدلا من الجيش الروسي
في الشكل يقترب حجم الدمار هنا ليشبه دمار
ستالينغراد في الحرب العالميه الثانيه لكن
بخمت التي لا تزيد مساحتها على 41
كيلومترا مربعا لا تقارن باهميه
ولا بمساحتها التي تزيد على
859 كيلومترا مربعا فلماذا يستمر القتال
بين الروس والاوكرانيين في باخموت منذ
ثمانيه اشهر
هي قلعه لمعنوياتنا هكذا وصف الرئيس
الاوكراني المدينه وصف يكاد يقترب من
اسباب استمرار القتال
لن نسلم بخموت سنقاتل طالما امكننا ذلك
باخ مت قلعتنا ومن ماتوا فيها نعتبرهم
ابطالا واذا تسلمنا اسلحه بعيده المدى فلن
ننسحب من بخمس وسنبدا باستعاده دومباس
فباخمت لا تحمل اي اهميه استراتيجيه في
الحرب بشكل عام والانسحاب منها في الحاله
الاوكرانيه لا يفرض واقعا جديدا بحسب وزير
الدفاع الامريكي بالنسبه لروسيا فان
الامساك يزيد من مساحه سيطرتها على اقليم
الدومباس التي ضمته الى اراضيها وقد يتيح
لها التقدم او على الاقل تامين الطريق
للتقدم باتجاه سلافيان
تقدم لن يكون سهلا على ايه حال نظرا
لتضاريس المنطقه ولهذا فان الاهميه التي
تحملها معركه بخموت ليست ميدانيه بحته
كياف حولت بخموت الى رمز للمقاومه لترسل
من وراء القتال رساله ان الدعم الغربي
يمكنها من صد الهجمات الروسيه
وروسيا تريد نصرا معنويا بعد اشهر من
الجنود الميداني حتى لو كان الفصل شتاء
من الناحيه القانونيه سيطرنا على بخموت
وسيتولى القاده الذين حققوا هذا التقدم
رفع هذه الاعلام اعلى ميفاجنر وحتى لو كان
نصرا ممهورا بتوقيع فاجنر
[موسيقى]
وصل الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونل ترامب
الى نيويورك تاهبا للمثول امام المحكمه
غدا وقد وضعت عناصر شرطه نيويورك في حاله
تاهب وقال الناطق باسم شرطه نيويورك ان
الشرطه ستضمن للجميع امكانيه ممارسه حقهم
بطريقه سلميه اضاف انه لا توجد في الوقت
الراهن تهديدات جديه ويواجه ترامب تهمه
جنائيه واحده على الاقل في لائحه الاتهام
التي اقرتها هيئه محلفين في منهته من جهه
قال محامي ترامب ان موكله يواجه قضيه
اضطهاد سياسي في القضيه المرفوعه ضده
بنيويورك
وهذا الصور تردنا مباشره من نيويورك لتجمع
بعض انصاري ترامب الذي كما ذكرنا وصل الى
الولايه وهو
بحسب اخر المعلومات في طريقه الى مقر
اقامته في منهجه
[موسيقى]
تنضم الينا من امام محكمه منهت بمدينه
نيويورك مراسله الجزيره بسان ابو كويك
ومعنى من محيط مطار ويسبون بيتش في
فلوريدا مراسل الجزيره ناصر الحسيني مرحبا
بكما سنبدا معك بيسان دعينا في صوره
الاجواء في نيويورك في هذه الاثناء
هي اجواء امنيه وتشديدات وانتشار مكثف
لعناصر الشرطه حتى اللحظه معظم الشوارع
والطرق في هذه المدينه مفتوحه ولكن هناك
تواجد كثيف لعناصر الشرطه ال سي رئيس
ترامب وصل بالفعل الى برج ترامب او ما
يسمى
ودخل المبنى دون ان يدلي باي تصريحات ان
كان للاعلام او لاي من الحشود الذين
يتجمعون خارج ذلك المبنى هنا في امام
المحكمه لم نرصد تواجدا لاي من مؤيدي
الرئيس السابق ربما رايت منذ الصباح سوى
شخصين يحملان شعارات مؤيده
لترامب ولكن طبعا هناك تواجد كثيف لوسائل
الاعلام وعناصر الشرطه كان هناك طلب من
وسائل اعلام امريكيه قدمت
المحكمه بالسماح
لكاميرات بالتواجد داخل قاعه المحكمه حين
يمثل ترامب يوم غد الثلاثاء امام القاضي
حيث سيتم تلاوه التهم عليه فريق ترامب رده
بمعارضه هذه الفكره قائلا ان وجود
الكاميرات سيؤدي الى خلق حاله من الصحب
والفوضى وسائل الاعلام تدفع بضروره وجودها
بسبب حساسيه الموقف غير المسبوق وهذا
المشهد غير المسبوق يعني ودفعا للشفافيه
ننتظر خلال ربما لحظات او الساعه المقبله
ان يدلي قاضي برايه ان كان سيسمح بالفعل
لوجود الكاميرا داخل القاعه ولكن عموما
الكل يستعد ليوم غد هذا اليوم الذي لم
ربما حدث لم يسبق له مثيل في التاريخ
الامريكي وكنت قد اعددت السي تقريرا
قبل في وقت سابق اليوم حول الاجراءات
الامنيه والمتوقع يوم غد حين يحضر ترامب
الى هنا الى مبنى هذه المحكمه في منهاتن
لنتابع
بمرافقه شرطه الخدمه السريه وفي ظل
اجراءات امنيه مشدده ومظاهرات متوقعه
سيحضر الرئيس الامريكي السابق دون ترامب
في حدث غير مسبوق لتوجه اليه تهم رسميا من
قبل قادم في هذا المبنى وكما جرت العاده
مع الرئيس السابق من المتوقع ان يثير
الحدث اهتماما وسخبا اعلاميا
وجودها امام المحكمه وخارج برج ترامب حيث
سيقضي الرئيس السابق ليلته قبل احتجازه
تحسبا لاي طارئ في ظل دعوات من مناصريه
وشخصيات جمهوريه للتظاهر حين يصل ترامب
الى المحكمه يتوقع ان تؤخذ بصماته وربما
صورته في حين لم يعرف بعد ان كان سيكبل
كما يحدث عاده مع المتهمين وقبيل مثوله
امام القاضي سينتظر في احدى الغرف بدلا من
زنزانه وفق ما نقلته صحيفه نيويورك تايمز
ومن ثم يتوقع ان يصور ترامب من قبل وسائل
الاعلام وهو في طريقه لقاعه المحكمه حيث
ستكشف لائحه الاتهام الموجهه اليه رسميا
من قبل القاضي
وصفاتهامه على خلفيه قضيه دفع اموال
لاسكات ممثله اباحيه بانها ملاحقه سياسيه
ليعزز من هجماته على المدعي العام لمنهاات
الفن براغ
ترامب يستعد لهذه المعركه ومن الواضح انها
قضيه اضطهاد سياسي واعتقد ان ناس سواء
المعارضون او المؤيدون له يعتقدون انها
اساءه كامله لاستخدام السلطه رجل قوي
وسيكون مستعدا لهذه المعركه ونحن ايضا
كفريق محاميين جاهزون ونتطلع للمضي قدما
باسرع ما يمكن لتبرئته رغم انه لم يكشف
بعد عن طبيعه التهم والتي يتوقع ان تفوق
العشرين الا ان طائفه واسعه من الجمهوريين
بما في ذلك شخصيات تنتقده وصفت اتهامه
بتطاول سياسي احداث تلك الشخصيات وزير
العدل السابق الذي اعرب عن قلقه من
تداعيات القضيه على مستقبل البلاد في حين
التزم الديمقراطيون بالدعوه الاحترام سير
العمليه القضائيه
من الامور التي احترمتها الولايات المتحده
دوما سياده القانون ومن المحق اخطاء رئيس
سابق لنفس القانون كاي شخص اخر في البلاد
لكن لكل مدعي تقيمه واذا تمت ملاحقه شخص
فقط لانه رئيس سابق وليس بسبب جديه
الجريمه فسيكون هناك انحراف عن سياده
القانون
وفق احدث استطلاعا للراي اعرب 45% من
الامريكيين عن تاييدهم لتهام ترامب في حين
عارض ذلك 32% وفي حين يامل محامو ترامب ان
تمضي اجراءات احتجازه بسرعه من المقرر ان
يعود الرئيس السابق الى مقر اقامته في
فلوريدا ليختتم يوما سيسجل في التاريخ
الامريكي بكلمه يلقيها هناك بسبب كويك
الجزيره نيويوركا
اذا كما ذكرت بيسان
وصل الى مقر اقامته في ترامبور على كل حال
لسان ابو كويك في نيويورك تبقين معنا في
المتابعه في كل جديد بما يتعلق بهذا الوضع
الى فلوريدا حيث يتواجد مراسلنا ناصر
الحسيني ناصر ترامب كان انطلق من فلوريدا
وتعاهد لانصاره بانه سيعود بعد مثوله امام
المحكمه بالعوده الى مقر اقامه في فلوريدا
والقاء كلمه ماذا في التفاصيل والاجواء
هناك
انطلق قبل ساعتين من هنا قرب المطار
نحو نيويورك وقد وصل الان الان فلوريدا
وباقي الولايات المتحده باقي الجمهوريين
عبر الولايات الامريكيه ينتظرون وينظرون
الان نحو نيويورك لتلك الجلسه الخاطفه غدا
هناك الثلاثاء في نيويورك ثم بعدها سيعود
هنا الى مقر اقامه حيث يوجد الان كما ترون
ورائي هذه الان لكن غدا ستشهد حركه غير
مسبوقه ايضا للاعلاميين ننتظر غدا حول
الثامنه ليلا رابعه الخامسه صباحا بتوقيت
الدوحه اول كلمه او اول مؤتمر صحفي للرئيس
الامريكي الاسبق بعد مثله امام المحكمه في
نيويورك واضح جدا ان حمله الرئيس ترامب
ستستغل وبذكاء يجب قول هذا هذا الحدث
اليوم قبل قليل فقط اطلق الرئيس الاسبق
الامريكي العنان ايضا لكلماته وبيانه
الصحفيه وذكر قبل قليل في بيان مكتوب
للصحافه والاعلام
وبعدها سيبدا ايضا الصراع السياسي على
مستوى الحزب الجمهوري ومن سيمثل هذا الحزب
المنقسم في امريكا اصلا شكرا لك ناصر
الحسين مراسلنا من محيط مطار ويسبون بيتش
في فلوريدا
ابو كويك حدثتنا من امام المحكمه محكمه
مانها بمدينه نيويورك
للمزيد حول هذا الموضوع معنا من نيويورك
محمد سطوحي الكاتب الصحفي المختص في الشان
الامريكي سيد محمد هل يمكن ان تنطوي
المحاكمه غدا على مفاجات
لا اعتقد ان هناك مفاجات هناك اجراءات
روتينيه معتاده في مثل هذه الاحوال
الاسئله المحيطه بها هي فقط مرتبطه بما
اذا كان سيتم تصويره اغلب الظن الان انه
لن يتم تصويره لانه هذا اولا سيكون مزعجا
جدا للرئيس الامريكي السابق بان يتم
تصويره
كمتهم على الاقل وربما يتم نشر هذه الصور
اغلب الظن انه هذه الصور تتم التقاطها فقط
في حاله المتهمين لكي يتم نشرها اذا ما
هرب من العداله ولكن لا يوجد احد لا يعرف
وجه دونالد ترامب فلا توجد ضروره قانونيه
ولا يوجد الزام قانوني للمحكمه بان يتم
تصويره غير ذلك سيتم اخذ البصمات الخاصه
به واذا كان هناك مفاجات ستكون في تجمع
عدد كبير من الناس لا اعتقد انه التجمعات
ستكون مظاهرات ضخمه او عنيفه كما راينا في
احداث يناير منذ عامين ولكن ربما يكون
هناك مجموعات امام برج ترامب او امام
المحكمه ولكن تم اتخاذ الاجراءات اللازمه
من جانب البوليس بحيث لا يكون هناك تطور
كبير لها او احداث عنف حتى الان التجمعات
تبدو خجوله جدا في مدينه نيويورك بحسب ما
ذكرت
مراسلتنا هل من دلاله معينه لذلك خصوصا ان
ترامب كان في الاسبوع الماضي دعا انصاره
للتظاهر
حدث ذلك بالفعل ولم لم تقم مظاهرات كبيره
كما توقع البعض حتى امام مره لاجو المكان
الذي يقيم به كان هناك تجمع عشرات الافراد
على الاكثر وانضوا بعض الوقت ثم ذهبوا الى
بيوتهم لا توجد حتى الان مؤشرات على انه
هناك تجمعات كبيره من الممكن ان تحدث ولكن
كما يقال يجب ان تامل في الافضل وتستعد
للاسوء هناك حواجز امنيه في بعض المناطق
في منهاتنا الان حتى لا يتم التجمع بشكل
ضخم يهدد الامن ومسيره الحياه في نيويورك
المؤشرات تقول لا ولكن لا نعلم قبل
حجزي في المحكمه لاخذ بصمات ربما يكون
هناك تجمعات وهذا ما سوف ننتظر لنراه طبعا
الان هناك استقطاب كبير في الولايات
المتحده حيال هذا الموضوع وهذه المحاكمه
بين الجمهوريين والديمقراطيين السؤال كيف
يمكن ان يؤثر هذا المسار في المدى الطويل
على
الانتخابات الرئاسيه وتحديدا على حمله
ترامب
بالنسبه هو يريد ان يستفيد قدر الامكان
مما يحدث الان لا اقول انه سعيد بانه سيتم
او سيتوجه الى المحكمه ويتم توجيه
الاتهامات اليه فيها لا اعتقد انه اي شخص
سيكون سعيدا بذلك هذه مشكله كبيره وخطيره
في حقيقه الامر ولكنه كالمعتاد يحاول
الاستفاده من اي شيء يمر به يقولون انهم
جمعوا سبعه ملايين دولار حتى الان في
حملته الانتخابيه من التبرعات بعد الاعلان
عن التهامه ربما يكون هناك ايضا استفاده
حقيقيه انه اغلب منافسين يمتنعون الان عن
توجيه اي انتقادات له حتى لا يسيء اليهم
ذلك في حملاتهم الانتخابيه
ربما يفيد ذلك على المدى القصير في
الانتخابات التمهيديه للحزب الجمهوريه
السؤال هل يفيده ذلك في الانتخابات العامه
اذا ما فاز في الانتخابات التمهيديه اعتقد
انه هذا سيكون سؤالا اكبر ورب ثم تاتي هذه
الامور اليه لتضره فيما بعد باعتباره
الرئيس السابق التهامه جنائيا والسابق
ايضا توجيه الاتهامات اليه في مجلس النواب
مرتين في اثناء فتره الانتخابيه شكرا
لك محمد الصلحي الكاتب الصحفي المختص في
الشان الامريكي من نيويورك
[موسيقى]
تتواصل ردود الفعل السياسيه والاقتصاديه
على قرار دول اوبك بلاس خفض انتاجها طوعيا
بدءا من مايو المقبل حتى نهايه العام فبعد
ساعات من الخطوه التي وصفت بالهزه سجلت
اسعار النفط اكبر زياده يوميه منذ عام
وتدافع دول بلس عن قرارها بانه يهدف الى
تحقيق التوازن والاستقرار في السوق بعد
تدهور الاسعار منذ مارس الماضي الا ان
الولايات المتحده التي تطالب منذ مده برفع
الانتاج لمواجهه التضخم وتداعيات الحرب في
اوكرانيا وصفت القرار بانه غير صائب
ما يرضي تكتل اوبك بلاس يزعج اخرين
استيقظت الاسواق العالميه على ارتفاع
اسعار الذهب الاسود لاول مره منذ نحو عام
بعد يوم فقط من قرار الدول الكبرى المنتجه
والمصدره خفض انتاجها اعتبارا من مايو
المقبل حتى نهايه العام ارتفع خام برنت
اثناء التداولات بنحو السته في المئه
مقتربا من 85 دولارا للبرميل كما اقترب
خام غرب تكساس من عتبه 80 دولارا للبرميل
بصيغ مختلفه في الشكل ولكنها تحمل نفس
المضمون بررت الدول وقرارها الذي وصف
بالهزه وغير الحكيم من بعض الرافدين له
اجمعت البيانات على ان الهدف هو رفع
الاسعار بعد التدهور الاخير الذي سجل منذ
مارسي الماضي وتكررت فيها عبارات الاجراء
الاحترازي وتحقيق الاستقرار والتوازن في
سوق الخام فقد اتفقت تسع دول من بينها
السعوديه والام والكويت والسلطنه عمان
والجزائر بشكل منسق على تقليص انتاجها
اليومي باكثر من مليون برميل استنادا
للجنه المتابعه الوزاريه المشتركه لدول
اوبك بلس فان حجم التخفيض الطوعي لانتاج
النفس سيكون مليونا
الف برميل يوميا على نفس الخطى صارت روسيا
المنضويه في التكتل اذ اعلنت تمديد خفض
انتاجها من النفط الخام بخمس مئه الف
برميل يوميا حتى نهايه السنه دفعت موسكو
عن خطوه التي لم تعجب من يسعون لعزلها
ومعاقبتها على الحرب في اوكرانيا قال
المتحدث باسم الكرم
انه من مصلحه اسواق الطاقه العالميه ان
تبقى اسعار النفط في مستوى جيد سواء كانت
الدول الاخرى سعيده بذلك ام لا بعبارات
القلق والخشيه عبرت الوكاله الدوليه
للطاقه التي تتخذ من باريس مقرا لها عن
موقفها
وفقه بيانها تخفيضات اوبك بلس تثير خطر
تفاقم اضطراب السوق ورفع اسعار النفط وسط
ضغوط التضخم بعيدا عن القراءات الجيوسيه
التي تفرضها الحرب في اوكرانيا وتغير
التحالفات والتكتلات في العالم لكل طرف
وجهه نظر يدافع عنها ومن اجلها مصلحه
اقتصادات الدول الكبرى المنتجه والمصدره
للنفط تقتضي مواجهه انهيار الاسعار بخفض
الانتاج بالنسبه للولايات المتحده
والاتحاد الاوروبي ما حدث ضربه موجعه
مزدوجه القرار يزيد من تداعيات التضخم في
الاقتصادات الكبرى ويقوض الجهود الراميه
الى تقليص عائده روسيا من النفط وميزانيه
حربها المكلفه في اوكرانيا القراءه
اللافته لكل ما جرى منذ الاحد وسيجري على
مدى الشهور القادمه هو وحده وتماسك دول
اوبك بلاس في وجه كل الضغوط حتى لو كانت
من حديث تقليدي واستراتي جي
نعود الان الى موضوع انضمام فنلندا الى
حلف الناتو وما الذي يضيفه ذلك على خريطه
الحلف عام 1949 اسس الحلف وكانت خريطه كما
نرى اثنان عشره دوله اهمها الولايات
المتحده وبريطانيا وفرنسا وكندا والهدف
كان مواجهه الجبهه الشرقيه ممثله بالاتحاد
السوفيتي الساعي للتمدد وحتى عام 1991
كانت الخريطه على النحو التالي وهو العام
الذي لم يعد فيه الاتحاد السوفيتي موجودا
نرى هنا روسيا وهذا الخط الفاصل بين من
الدول بينها وبين النيجر ما بعد عام 1997
شهدت حدود الحلفي اتساعا كبيرا نحو روسيا
كما نرى هنا حيث باتت المنطقه الفاصله
جزءا من الحفظ اهم الدول كانت هولندا التي
انضمت عام 1999 لان ذلك كان تحولا معنويا
اذ كانت تضم الحلف المناو الى الناتو اي
حلف وورسو وكذلك دول البلطيق الثلاث عام
2004 وهي التي عانت تحول الاستراتيجيا
بحدودها المباشره مع روسيا اليوم تزداد
حدوث النيتو المباشره مع روسيا
1340 كيلومترا دفعه واحده بانضمام فنلندا
وهو تحول كبير بلا شك لم يتمدد حلف الناتو
جغرافيا فقط بل وسع مهامه ايضا وخريطه
اهدافه رغم انهيار حلف ورسو وانتهاء الحرب
البارده وغير ذلك من الاحداث وتوجه تعزز
اكثر بعد حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا يتعلق
الامر اليوم بما يمكن اعتباره عولمه من
خلال اقامه الحلف دروعا صاروخيه في اسيا
لتطويق روسيا والصين وحلفائهما في تلك
المنطقه مثل كوريا الشماليه ويستفيد
الناتو من علاقات واشنطن الوثيقه مع كوريا
الجنوبيه واليابان حيث يقوموا البلدان
بدور اساسي في اقامه تلك الدروع وتنفيذ
السياسه العسكريه للحلف في الشرق الاقصى
كما انشات المتحده وحلف الناتو قوات بحريه
مهمتها مراقبه حركه التجاره في المياه
الدوليه وتفتيش السفن في اعالي البحار
بذريعه ايقاف تهريب مكونات او تقنيه اسلحه
الدمار الشامل لكن عسكرت طرق المواصلات
العالميه تسعى ايضا الى تامين احتياجات
اعضاء الحلف من الطاقه عملا بعقيده جديده
لا تفرق بين عضو واخر ويضطر للخضوع بسبب
منع تزويده بالطاقه وعضو يواجه خطرا
عسكريا
للمزيد حول هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا من
باريس زياد ماجد استاذه العلوم السياسيه
بالجامعه الامريكيه في باريس مرحبا بك
زياد ماجد ماذا يعني ان نتحدث عن عولمه
الناتو في هذه المرحله
يعني هناك بلا شك وكما تفضلتم في التقرير
توسعا استراتيجيا مهما اذ ان فنلندا تتيح
اكثر من الف واربعمائهكم
تماسك مباشر مع روسيا كما انها في منظور
الناتو تحمي دول البلطيق الثلاث
وليست الا على مسافه عشرات الكيلومترات من
من عاصمه
من تالين وهي ايضا قريبه للارض الروسيه في
المانيا القريبه من المانيا يعني بين
بولونيا
وروسيا البيضاء لذلك هناك تطور مهم يضاف
اليه مساله المتجمد الشمالي الذي يؤمن
للناتو الان
حضورا اساسيا في منطقه يتنافس عليها
الغربيون مع روسيا وطبعا فيما يخص حرب
اوكرانيا كانت احدى الذرائع الروسيه هي
الرغبه الاوكرانيه في الانضمام الى حلف
شمال الاطلسي فنحن الان نشهد دوله اخرى
كانت تاريخيا تفضل الحياد وحافظت عليه حتى
في عزل الحرب البارده ها هي الان تنضم الى
حلف شمال الاطلسي وتنتظر السويد ايضا
دورها فهذا التوسع هو لمصلحه حلف شمال
الاطلسي في هذه المنطقه لكنه حكما سيؤدي
الى المزيد من التوترات والى انتشارات
عسكريه وانتشارات مضاده وحشد لموازنات
ايضا تسلح متصاعده والحديث هنا ليس فقط عن
اوروبا وما يحدث مع فنلندا ولكن ايضا عن
اسيا عن افريقيا ماذا عن تمدد الحلف هناك
والتوترات التي يمكن ان يحدثها ذلك
ايضا هذا يرتبط بسياق التطور الامور
الاقتصاديه العالميه في منطقه اسيا
هي الهدف الاول او احتواء الصين عملاق
اقتصادي ينافس امريكا واصبحت له شركات
تتقدم على امريكا في افريقيا وفي امريكا
الجنوبيه وبعض دول اسيا كما انها حلفاء
امريكا هناك اليابان وكوريا الجنوبيه
وبالطبع تايوان يشعرون بهذا الصعود الكبير
للصين فتستفيد امريكا من ذلك من خلال نشر
قواتها هناك ومن خلال ليس محاص
ره لكن
يخفف او يبطئ من عمليه تمددها
المستقبليه المتوقعه لكن هل سياسه
الاحتواء هذه ناجحه لان عندما راينا ينسى
يتوجه الى اسيا راينا ايضا تصعيدا من جانب
كوريا الشماليه وحديث عن ضروره اقتناء
السلاح النووي
لا هي بالطبع ليست سياسه ناجحه
والدليل ان الصين ما زالت في صعودها
الاقتصادي على الاقل وفي تقدمها في عدد من
المناطق في العالم لاسيما في افريقيا
وامريكا الجنوبيه شركات اساسيه مع
البرازيل مع دول الكبرى مع جنوب افريقيا
كما ان عملتها بدات تدخل في سوق التداول
وهذا
منافس امريكا ما زالت تشعر بان مخزون
قوتها القديم والمستمر يقيها لسنوات تريد
ان تمددها من خلال هذه العمليات
الاحتوائيه وربما تفيد الاشاره الى ان
مرحله التسعينات تختلف عما بعدها التوسع
كان يومها يرتبط بالشعور بالانتصار في
الحرب البارده بانهيار الاتحاد السوفياتي
بمرحله صينيه لم تكن بعد على هذا التوسع
الاقتصادي الكبير اما ما بعد الالفين اصبح
الموضوع يرتبط فعليا بمواجهات كانت قد
بدات يعني روسيا كانت في مناطق القوقاز في
الشيشان في داغستان تفرض بالقوه سطوتها ثم
بعد ذلك جاءت استونيا الجنوبيه من بعدها
مراحل اوكرانيا والتوترات حتى قبل الحرب
جورجيا الى اخره
كانت ايضا في مرحله صعود بعد الالفين
وبالتالي تحول اداء امريكا الى اداء ربما
اكثر هجوميه
النظر بكين وموسكو اكثر عدائيه
كيف يمكن لروسيا والصين وهذه الشراكه
والتقارب بين هاتين الدولتين يتصرفان
عولمه النيتو كما نقول
هذا هو الره الاساسي واعتقد على عكس ربما
ما يظنه البعض ان في هذا الثنائي الروسي
الصيني الصيني هي لها الدور الاوزن لانها
صاحبه الاقتصاد الاوسع وهي تحتاج لطاقه
الروسيه وهذا ما يعطي روسيا يعني حضورا
اساسيا في هذا الثنائي لكن توسع اقتصاد
الصين اهم بكثير من مخدرات روسيا على
التعامل معه بنديه كما ان الحرب في
اوكرانيا التي تنهك روسيا ستكون ايضا
لصالح الصين هي هو تجميع ايضا وهو رساله
للغرب الى ان بعض الدول تملك خيارات اخرى
وتستطيع توسيع تحالفاتها في عالم انتهت
فيه احاديه القطبيه لكننا لم نشهد بعد
ثنائيه او ثلاثيه لان الفرق مازال كبيران
وحين كان الاتحاد السوفيتي ينافس امريكا
كان لديه مشروع ايديولوجي بديل مشروع
اشتراكي مشروع ربما نستطيع تقييمه
انماط مختلفه لكنه كان يطرح على الاقل او
يدعي طرحه بديل الان لا يوجد بديل عن
الراسماليه الصين هي راسماليه دوله روسيا
راس ماليتها متوحشه
كصراع ايديولوجي في هذه الثنائيه او
الثلاثيه التي يحاول البعض ايجادها وهناك
هيمنه ثقافيه للغرب ترتبط بالطب بالعلوم
بالتكنولوجيا بالتعليم حتى نخب
الصين اذا ارادت ان تتعلم تذهب الى جامعه
استاذ العلوم السياسيه بالجامعه الامريكيه
في باريس اشكرك سنكتفي بهذا القدر لم يعد
لدينا وقت شكرا جزيلا لك
[موسيقى]
لم تنتهي اخبار الزلزال الذي ضرب تركيا
وسوريا وهز بفاجعته العالم جيزيم قصه امل
وسط الماساه الممتده طفله انتشلت حيه لكن
دون اهل وبقيت منذ ذلك الحين حتى يوم امس
في مركز رعايه حكومي قبل ان يجسر العلم
قوه الماساه ويكشف فحص الحمض النووي هويه
الام لتستعيد الطفله اسمها الاصلي وهو
فاتن انطوت ماساه الطفله لكن 2003 عشره
طفلا اصيبوا ونجوا ولم يعثر على ذويهم على
امل نهايه الحصاد لهذه الليله اترككم الان
مع سلمى وعبد القادر وجوله منتصف الليل
الى اللقاء شكرا لمتابعتكم